we've come to Sweden northwest of
Stockholm you'll find the world's
deepest underground hotel suite
located 55 metres below the surface in a
disused mine it's named simply the mine
sweet
Linda and Dennis have traveled all over
but they're quite excited about trying
out this hotel the chicken is above
ground here they meet Myka who will
accompany them into the depths welcome
you're gonna sleep underground in the
mine suite so that you will need helmets
and you will need torches the solar mine
was once the number one supplier of
silver in Europe it operated for
centuries it's a huge labyrinth of
underground tunnels just getting to the
mine suite is an experience now the
elevator will make a lot of noise but
that's exactly the way it should be
it takes four and a half minutes for the
old lift to descend the 155 meters
welcome to winter cold inside the mine
it's a chilly two degrees Celsius and
feels slightly death worn clothes are a
must for anyone planning to spend the
night this far below ground the path to
the underground suite is long dark and
confusing then suddenly Hotel guide mica
begins to sing
singing in the depths is an old
tradition the miners used to sing psalms
as they believed grew from the female
spirit of the mine would then protect
them
by knocking in the bedrock three times
you tell her that you've arrived and she
knows how many of us she needs to
protect and after that just please don't
whistle
don't yell at each other and don't spit
on the floor because the lady of the
mine does not like that the suite itself
is heated to a pleasant 20 degrees it
shouldn't be comfortable but it is in a
strange way you feel really calm the
core not stressed at all just really
really loud yeah but there are unusual
noises in the mine and it can get a bit
creepy 100 feet ago voice whenever I
that this is you she didn't you hear so
many sounds you'd expect it to be very
quiet here but you can always hear
something it could be the heating or the
elevator water dripping and sometimes
the sounds are so unexpected that you
want to talk to someone else about it so
it's good if there's two of you staying
here so it's why it's as I'm a hotel is
a hotel this is something completely
different
yeah
this is not something you come across
each day if you like to travel a lot and
you have seen a lot of places I think
you missed out this because even if you
seen this from afar you have no idea
what it's like down here there is no
real bathroom underground but there is
at least a toilet it's a full 50 meters
away which means heading back into the
freezing cold there's no shower or wash
basin very easy at a price of five
hundred and fifty euros a night this
week does have room service guests can
radio their request to the reception and
there's always someone available in case
of emergency business it guides Muslim
it's a safety measure
but since the elevator takes over four
minutes to get down here it takes a
while anyway so we decided that somebody
needed to sleep upstairs so that they
could be here quickly
if someone begins to panic or something
like that it's good to know that
someone's nearby if you need them recent
as human in any years
spending a night in an old silver mine
is truly an out-of-this-world experience